[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
do
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
ah
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
what is popping everyone welcome to day
two of the gorilla collective two
i'm so happy to be here i'm your host
justin woodward co-founder of the mix
the media in the exchange
and indie game team in terra bang
entertainment i am with my
co-host and beautiful friend alex wilmer
oh you're beautiful
what's happening um i
well i'm thrilled to be back for day two
the guerrilla collective so many great
games on day one
i'm very excited to see what we have in
store for day two
so much good stuff last week we flexed
on you with some dope games from neon
doctrine
save some cuties in the eternal cylinder
and showcase some up-and-coming games
from bit summit as well as brought
diversity to the mix
pun intended with black voices in gaming
the gorilla collective is a grassroots
movement
funded and supported by devs and close
partners
down for the cause it was initially
started as a global coalition
of leading game studios publishers and
industry leaders coming together to help
bring new announcements
gameplay and reveals from studios of all
sizes
direct to game enthusiasts all of you
guys
worldwide we will continue the movement
today starting with a few announcements
exclusives and premieres and then
connect with our friends at wholesome
direct
to share the latest and greatest cozy
games that will give you the warm and
fuzzies
all over your body
before we get started though we have to
give a huge shout
out to our sponsors and this is quite a
mouthful
shout outs to good shepherd humble games
tiny build playstation xbox kickstarter
razer astro gaming our fellow devs and
publishers two awesome studio
akupara games all in games goblin studio
graffiti games head up hype train
digital
neon doctrine raw fury thunderful and
white thorn
games good job i did it
and we've also teamed up with valve to
showcase the games
on steam in order to support these devs
so be sure to check out the gorilla
collective event page on
steam where you can learn more about
these games buy the games that are
available now
and add the games to your wish list for
games that are not
yet out so check out
steam event page which is on the gorilla
collective website
gorillacollective.com.com
i barely made it through this it was
good
shout out to our broadcasting partners
for supporting and hosting the stream
twitch steam ign and gamespot if it
wasn't for your guys help this would not
have been possible but enough lip
smacking and yakking
let's get started with a few brand new
exclusive indie titles
and an update from a game that we're all
looking forward to checking out
i know you can't wait can you nope
definitely not let's go
hi everyone i'm gina community manager
at lengthy works
we are so excited to be able to show you
this gameplay sneak peek of varagami 2
our second game arriving september 17th
on pc
xbox one and series playstation 4 and
playstation 5.
aragami 2 is a third person stealth game
where you play as an assassin with the
power to control the shadows
as part of your clan you'll have to
fight the invader armies to protect your
people
and to find a cure to the evil that
afflicts you
the main pillars of arvakami 2 are
stealth in its core
all new combat mechanics and the robust
co-op multiplayer system
this goes along with the newly designed
character progression
customization and a wide variety of
abilities and shadow powers
so which player can live this new story
in their own way
stealth is the heart of origami too and
we wanted the player to actually feel
like a ninja
to be fast and agile to use the
environment in its favor
and the shadow powers to feel more
organic
now you can navigate through the map in
a more fast and responsive way
you can double jump you can use dash and
shadow lip while in the air
you can hold on the walls and ledges the
whole experience of character movement
is fun and gratifying
we also introduced a special stealth
cover so now the character can interact
with the special props
like tall grass bashes and other vision
of clothing areas
in order to acquire special stealth
behaviors and permitting contextual
kills and chaos
as for the shadow powers we maintain
some of the original ones and
added a bunch more as well as abilities
and items
let's now check out some combat since
zaragami choose a stealth game
we challenge ourselves to create a
combat system based on supernatural
ninja skills
which also encourages stealth over brute
force
we thought the best way to achieve this
was to give our character
agile and skillful movement which
empowers superfoods
and stealth assault instead of a lot of
strength
and also reinforcing the feeling of
being outnumbered by the enemy
[Music]
and that's all for now thanks for
watching and we hope to have you
embarking on this journey
on september 17th
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
group
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
hello my name is josh sullivan and i'm a
designer on bpm
bullets per minute bpm is a roguelike
rhythm first person shooter game where
all of your actions and the actions of
your enemies
are tied to the beat of our epic rock
opera soundtrack
everything you do in bpm is tied to the
beat of the music
this includes shooting and reloading
your weapon
[Music]
see how satisfying that sounds your goal
is to reach the end of our procedurally
generated dungeons
collecting different weapons abilities
and items
each time you play these weapons and
abilities can
radically alter the way you play making
each play through
unique as the enemies are also tied to
the beat of the music
fighting them can become an epic rhythm
battle making you the player
feel like you're taking part in the
soundtrack itself
through your actions
[Music]
clearing each room will reward you with
loot the better you handled clearing the
room
the better the reward each floor has
either an armory or a library
where you can buy cool new weapons or
find exciting
game-changing abilities that make
slaying enemies to the beat
even more satisfying you can also find
shops to purchase
useful items for your run unfortunately
you cannot pet the bird maybe next time
though
each floor has its own boss and attacks
in a unique way
that you must learn to exploit if you
want to succeed
[Music]
finishing off a boss is a dramatic
musical crescendo that
you the player are in full control of
executing
bpm is out now on pc but is coming to
playstation 4
and xbox one this summer we can't wait
to see you slay the hordes of helheim
to the beat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm sal davison and i'm hanalee
and we are hubble grove
[Music]
no longer home is a story game about
graduating university
and anticipating what comes next or
struggling with borders
self identity and long ethnic
domesticity
[Music]
in no longer home you play as non-binary
protagonists bones out who are based off
cell and myself
[Music]
you'll explore an intimate flat filled
with everyday objects
delve into bone dials thoughts and
insights and mold your interpretation of
the characters through branching
multiple choice dialogue
the events in this game are based off
our own experiences
and many of the characters and stories
are based of people we know in real
life at the time we are feeling
disillusioned with education
disoriented and not sure what to do next
blur now
try to figure out their place in the
world
[Music]
making this project we wanted to
celebrate the magic of
everyday domestic mundanity like having
barbecues
playing video games and staying up late
just talking in bed
hannah and i started work on no longer
home six years ago
after we graduated university we met on
the same course
and during the last year we moved in
together
after graduation i unfortunately had to
go back to japan
how do you say goodbye to a place we
started making no longer home as a way
to stay in touch
but it rapidly grew as we realized how
much we had to talk about and all the
feelings we had to process
thanks so much for watching everyone no
longer home will be launching later this
year so please don't forget to wish this
on steam
man origami 2 is looking so fantastic i
need some of that stealth action in my
life
yep and fire girl that looks pretty
unique too
up next we have some magic and sword
play popping off in the next segment
with an update from a bonafide classic
and a new entry in the hybrid puzzle and
strategy realm
guard your loot and upgrade your boots
because we're about to slap you in the
face
with a spike ball mace bars
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
greetings friends senior game designer
saleem grant here to talk about the bard
stylish and flamboyant the bard uses the
magic of music to defeat their enemies
and cure their allies
this twisting of song and magic created
a versatile gameplay opportunity we felt
was compelling enough
to make this our next class while
they're dowsing their enemies with
dancing lights weaving in and out of the
fray or conducting a frenzied symphony
of combat
the bard never shies away from pulling
out their instruments or string a few
notes together
no matter what is needed a bard is
always ready to take center stage and
perform
and when the day is done their enemies
defeated and their allies safe
the bar becomes a source of entertaining
ballads and jingles and recount their
tales of triumph
with that we have reached the last
crescendo but fret not for we are not at
the finale just yet
there is more of this ballad that will
be revealed over the next few months
so please stay tuned
hey everyone i'm mira a developer from
striker studio a small slovakian based
company that is working on a game called
loot river
load river is essentially an action
roadway which is about shifting dungeons
around coming to xbox
and pc and i would like to show you a
new gameplay video which
shows you a controls of the game a
procedural generation
used in the game shows you some areas a
bit of combat
and perhaps a new thing or two that you
didn't see in the trail
okay let's actually take it a bit slower
let's start
i'll show you some controls you can move
your hero around with the
left stick responding to your pressure
and you can also dash
and dodge on controller with the a
button
and you attack with the right bumper
that's your standard attack
it now chains into combos it used to be
just like one attack before but now it's
like one two three fluidly changing into
one another
or a better feel of combat you can also
do a heavy attack
or what you could do is charge your
heavy attack for special damage
right and there are many different
weapons in luke river
and it is useful in different scenarios
and has
different properties and you can do
different stuff with
let's go to the first combat area now
the sunken village
it's the first area where you already
need to navigate these platforms that we
saw before and you do it by standing on
the platform
and dragging it to the right upwards
downwards or in any direction
and let's approach these enemies up now
and learn them onto our platform
yeah one by one if you want
all what we could do instead is just
like charge right in
and do some heavy attacks and hopefully
but that's usually not the best idea
unless you have a large weapon so
instead we could
you know always like isolate them into
parts
or we could skip them completely and go
for the big guy here instead it's very
dangerous
so what i'm gonna do instead is charge
my attack and slam the platform into
right for special damage
you see the levels of blue river are
procedural but they are handcrafted at
the same time
what we do is design lots of smaller
areas from possible connections
and then let the computer assemble them
and
look for logical relations in between
them
so even from small pool of objects we're
already getting some interesting
variations
in the levels enemies evolve for combat
on the platforms
some can even lock platforms together
preventing you from fighting away until
you defeat
your ability back others might really
long-range weapons
jump platforms or cause devastating
damage
however most of them have a weakness
hairy enemies burn really well
you will visit many interesting places
obtain
legendary weapons need unimaginable
characters
and ultimately die by your hand
but those who persist can get even
further
explore places never seen before face
horrors and perish again
loot river really has me intrigued i
really like what they're doing with the
combat and the uh the tetris
like platforming elements so cool yeah
and um
demon mirror has really great sound
you're just dude you're just saying that
because you worked on that game
yeah so what do we got coming up next
up next we have some dark and sinister
titles
starting with a physical release trailer
of a
gorgeous and deadly first person action
runner
then we're jumping into a spoof on a
beloved stealth classic
and ending it with an exclusive trailer
from our friends at raw fury
let's go
[Music]
enough
[Music]
i'll handle things from here on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Applause]
[Music]
i was
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
oh no an evil fog is corrupting every
living creature
there is one that is immune who is this
mighty hero
a slime how can an adorable little slime
fight against this
this or that
wait where did it get that sword is that
a meter shower
how ice cream when did you get that
now there are two of them all right
slimes can be heroes
grab a friend and save the world from
oozy monsters and formidable bosses
discover different weapons and create
your own magical abilities
to express the way you want to venture
in
[Music]
slime heroes
[Music]
oh
demon turn
[Music]
yep
[Music]
ah i'm so excited we could finally
announce ps4 and ps5
there is a lot of platforms oh yeah
ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series x nintendo
switch steam epic game store
basically you'll be able to play demon
turf anywhere
yep but what is demon turf exactly well
lucy
take it away
so her goal is to take on the demon king
who pretty much owns his place
it's all order right and apparently he's
been challenging her for a while now
her best friend midgie is also part of
this epic quest
bad enough of all that let's check out
some gameplay yo season real time
[Music]
bieber's moveset in demon turf has a lot
of depth
yeah for sure it's all about combined
moves to feel badass
one of my favorite examples is this
tower climbing different ways you can
skip
so many parts of it
things really heat up though once you
unlock the turfs
yeah yanking enemies around
rolling down highways soaring through
the skies
[Music]
combine it all and you get to see runs
like these from our incredible
speedrunning community
still blows my mind every time
begin our probe we hope to see you pull
off some of these moves from deem tip
releases
sometime later this year
[Music]
things
[Music]
uh
three
[Music]
in 1972 a crack commando
unit threw me in a prison for a crime i
didn't commit
you're under arrest for a crime you
didn't commit
[Music]
hey a coin
hey buddy i have no paper here you are
you saved my ass
literally
you stole a one-eyed man's patch that
patch turned out to be handy to create a
lethal weapon what were you gonna shoot
pebbles depleted uranium balls
[Music]
the sewer was infested with assassin
rats felt like i was a huge chunk of
cheese
[Music]
[Music]
it's kill or be killed
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey this is matt developer of server
steel and i'm here to talk about some
cool ways players have been up
playing the demo i released so this
level you're typically supposed to kick
that door open and deal with all the
guys in the hallway
but players found a way to use the arm
cannon to carve a whole left of the door
like you saw
which gets you into this hallway it's a
little bit safer and there's some nice
weapons to find in there
a player did this cool thing where they
throw their weapon
down the hallway and then fight through
the hallway
by the time you're at the end of the
hallway you're low on ammo or you're out
of ammo
and you have a like a loaded weapon
ready to go
when i first saw that
uh players have been doing cool stuff
with nicholas and ai so you saw i just
got wrecked kicking down that door
but if i use the audio perception of ai
to kick a wall lure them over uh you can
set up ambushes
that's really useful in the harder
difficulties where and there is
difficulty one shot kills you so that's
been a really useful technique
there's one stunt in the game that i
didn't actually include in the tutorial
and that's the ability to jump and kick
off walls
and on my discord players have been
sharing really crazy footage where
in rooms like this with a really high
ceiling they are
jumping and kicking off enemies to get
loads of airtime they can use to get
really stylish kills
in the arcade mode you get points for
stylish kills
and um getting that air time and killing
enemies upside down really can rack up
your score
i i didn't expect players would figure
out more advanced stunts like this
um but there's a lot of really cool
footage of players doing stuff like that
i've been really thrilled with the how
players figured that out
uh and in one last clip yeah you could
see uh some content that wasn't featured
in the demo
a lot of players asked for enemy
outlines to help discern them so you can
see i've out of them here
and please ask for a double shotgun
which you see i'm rocking right now
i hope you enjoyed this preview of
severed steel it's slated for pc release
late summer of this year and if you like
what you saw definitely
give it a wishlist on steam if you are
console player there are also
playstation 4 and xbox one releases
planned for
uh shortly after pc uh thanks again
oh
every day
[Music]
now
[Music]
whichever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much raw fury for that
special exclusive footage
up next we have an exclusive reveal for
one of the most bloodiest
sprite based action platformers i have
ever seen
we will check in on a dark and beautiful
pixar rpg
help clean up a forensic nightmare and
then we are heading to an update from a
mystical masterpiece from one of our
best of the mix 2020 award winners
grab your hazmat suit alex oh why
because we're about to go in and get
grimy
let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
hello my name is yatzek vovatsky and i'm
the head of company development at broad
distance
we're established by bluebird team and
we've just celebrated our 12th birthday
our goal right now is to become a fully
realized double a studio
my name is christoph jumba i'm a writer
and game designer at draw distance
we make games with unique stories and
visual styles excellent soundtracks and
captivating gameplay
we are known for our vampire the
masquerade titles and studio cleaner
our next game is its sequel serial
cleaners a stealth action crime story
set in 90s nyc
my name is mickey mica and i lead a team
of 30 amazing game developers currently
working on three different projects
sarah cleaners is our biggest one so far
and it's set to launch later this year
we've got a good vibe and we're
expanding so come join us on our
adventure to the 90s
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
hello we are monocle and we're a small
very small studio from cologne in
germany
and what you see before you is our very
first game a cinematic platformer called
white shadows
so white shadows is basically a modern
fable it drops you off in this huge
weird vertical world that is called the
white city
even though it's really really dark and
in this white city
there are the rats and the wolves and
they're in charge and then there's the
pigs and the sheep who do all the work
and then there's the birds
who are or at least so they say to blame
for a deadly pandemic
[Music]
and then there's you little raven girl
trying to change all that so basically
this game is not really a platformer
it's more of a trip it kind of drops you
off in this really weird world
and if you imagine inside in tim burton
having a really mean
weird little baby born in 1984 then
you'd have this game
it's black and white it's dark it has to
do with a lot of stuff that is in our
world today
and it's also really entertaining
we as the developers think that is
really funny but people who've played it
tell us that it's really really dark
so you read the judge of that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
shout out to raji congrats on winning
best of the mix 2020 such an
awesome studio in out of india you know
uh also bats is looking mad
slick if i don't say so myself you know
what i mean um
but yeah before we move on to the next
segment we want to say thanks to our
broadcasting partners twitch
steam ign and of course
gamespot thank you guys for all your
help and hosting the stream
yep and also don't forget to check out
the guerrilla collective event page
on steam to wishlist the games play the
demos
from this event as well as from
wholesome direct
which is coming up next we have a link
on the gorilla collective website
gorillacollective.com
up next we're going to connect with our
friends at tinybuild
we're doing gargantuan things with
really creative indie developers
let's creep around the corner and say
hello to our neighbor debs working with
tinybuild
to peep what they have cooking up
[Music]
hello meatbag this is my game
despots game i will give you a group of
puny humans and you will lead them to
the end of the dungeon
if you can get past my cute little
robots
zombie wombies and flesh eating cabbage
ravages
despot's game is a roguelike auto
battler
that means that all the fighting happens
automatically
it also means permadeath and randomly
generated dungeons
in order to win your humans will need
weapons
or whatever you can find to use as a
weapon
combine different kinds of dumb items to
create your
own damn army your army needs to be
positioned
fed and genetically modified
just don't get too attached to your
little humans
they'll be dropping like flies let me
tell you a little secret
if you make it far enough in the dungeon
you'll get the chance to fight other
players
you probably think i came up with all
this in order to raise a perfect army
of mutated humans capable of conquering
the universe
right wrong i simply
enjoy watching pathetic humans hit each
other with refrigerators
you're in desperate game now
config games bears no responsibility for
salty tears broken keyboards busted
screens or therapy expenses due to the
effects of extended gaming sessions
not recommended for use by children
pregnant women or people who have loud
conversations on their phones in public
[Music]
[Music]
this is dustin and this is eric from
animal and we're the creators of ramen
along with our extremely small team of
passionate individuals really excited to
get this out to you
ramen's a food fighting arena game with
a bunch of quirks and twists
and today we're going to show you one of
our favorite game modes along with the
new work in progress mode that we've
been working on
so let's uh start with the meatball mode
yeah and uh meatball mode it's all about
putting the meat in the hole
the goal hole you gotta jump in and take
control
like what does that mean it sounds good
what does that mean well it's you know
it's basically kind of like katamari
where
the objective is to jump into a giant
meatball take control of it roll around
charge it up and shoot it into various
uh goal locations throughout the map
uh oh while basically avoiding enemies
and the onslaught of food that they
throw at you
next up bobo ball well bubble ball is
one of our newest work in progress game
modes but still a ton of fun
players are now packing ebola blast
shoots bubble balls
at a giant boba ball work together with
your taste buds to blast the giant boba
ball into the opposing team's goal
but look kills don't count in this mode
so prioritize getting the giant ball
from a to b
uh but a few balls in the face never
hurt anyone so blast your foes to keep
them from gaining control of the ball
lost your toes foes okay bros i guess
wait what's this written down about me
chassis we wrote that yeah it says uh
say something about meat chassis oh
yeah the old bag of meat and bones you
know the players the soup saviors
players can customize their character
almost however they want within our high
fashion highly polished configurator
zone
all right well within this configurator
zone thing when it comes to fashion we
got you covered with a trunk full of
different culinary styles
vibes and drips your soup slinger is
yours to design and decorate honestly
the world is your oyster decorate to
your heart's content oh and uh don't
forget your old pop pal
i think it's time to wrap it up here
yeah good idea thanks for tuning in to
watch our video and giving us
opportunity to talk your ears off about
ramen
pretty excited about it oh and that
being said be sure to hop into our
discord so you can be part of the play
test and help us perfect the recipe of
ramen yeah we hope you get a chance to
play we really appreciate all the
support you all have shown over the
course of development really means a lot
and motivates us bye thanks first
for stopping by
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
really
[Music]
have a happy humble day
[Music]
meet the creepy ai driven mr peterson
this character has one mission keeping
you from discovering his secrets
hello and welcome to hello neighbor 2.
in this game
you'll be playing as a local journalist
named quentin who is suspicious of his
creepy neighbor
mr peterson for those new to the hello
neighbor franchise
this is raven brooks the sort of town
where everyone keeps to themselves and
goes about their lives
normally you would too except a bunch of
people have gone missing
and there's just something strange about
your neighbor mr peterson
everyone is afraid of him there have
been rumors of children going to his
house and never being heard from again
some people say he likes to lock people
up in his basement
but no one has any proof so people just
try to avoid mr peterson
his odd house and ignore the strange
sounds coming from his basement that
night
you have a feeling that mr peterson is
behind all of the neighborhood
disappearances
but no one believes in your ideas and
theories and while you normally wouldn't
break into someone's house
you're the only one who believes
something is wrong and has
the guts to uncover the truth when you
break into mr peterson's house you'll be
going against an
ai that is constantly evolving
our goal for hello neighbor 2 is to
provide unique player experiences
this is an experience that is driven by
the community
mr peterson's behavior is a combination
of a neural network
and algorithms that allow him to
constantly learn from his experiences
with everyone who plays our game it
begins with the collection of player
activity
mr peterson takes note of player
behavior whether or not most players are
likely to hide in a closet
use a certain escape route or certain
objects as time progresses and he learns
mr peterson's behavior may change and
surprise you
how mr peterson plays in one encounter
with you might be different from the
next
all due to his encounters with the games
community as a whole
in this way the community's experience
with mr peterson
changes over time allowing for an ai
that is developed through community
actions
replayability and great stories of
neighborhood shenanigans
but these new experiences go beyond mr
peterson in hello neighbor 2
players can interact with all characters
in raven brooks and these characters
share the same ai core but behave
differently
and have their own stories for you to
discover so while you might think you're
just playing the game
you're really contributing to the
development and improvement of mr
peterson's ai
hope this presentation of our ai and
development gives you an idea of what to
expect in hello neighbor 2.
if you'd like to try an early access
version of hello neighbor 2 you can wish
list the game on steam and check out our
alphas on the microsoft store
thank you for watching and we'll see you
in the neighborhood
ahoy sailors
not this again trash
sailors pirate guide
every pirate knows that the real
treasure
is friendship
just kidding it's trash
i love you trash it's everything
fuel building materials and
weapons seriously just stuff
in as much trash as you can and let it
rip
just remember this raft is your only
home
take good care of it and if anyone dares
set foot here
hit him with all you got too many greedy
lovers
wanna get their hands on our marvelous
beautiful
trash defend it to your last breath
and steer carefully oh
and don't forget to fix anything that
breaks
ah scurvy builds [ __ ] son of a
seagull
if your enemies get close and the good
old ship's cannons aren't enough
try the newfangled trash technology
you have countless aces up your sleeve
use
anything you get your hands on
they want to steal our trash
let them try we'll hit them with
everything we
got
shout out to tinybuild they are
producing and publishing
some of the most amazing any titles
coming out ramen is looking
real fantastic yep yep and for our
gorilla collective 2 finale
we're going to head out with an
exclusive humbling conversation that we
had with inner sloth
the team behind among us and check in on
some fun and upbeat games
as well as take a trip back to the
arcade with some fun
retro throwback games before we finish
everything up
we are also going to go to exclusive
interview
with our friends at limited run games
let's rock welcome back to the gorilla
collective we have marcus bromander and
adria wallach from the interslop
dev team super happy to have you guys
uh hopping on the gorilla collective for
an interview
tell us about yourselves i'm marcus also
known as puffballs united
i'm one of the co-founders of inner
sloth
i worked on a lot of the art
the sound design game design and
miscellaneous other spots in the game
but no coding
hi i am adriel i'm the lead programmer
inner sloth
which means i lift in the code i make a
bunch of lists i tell the other
programmers what to do
and i fix bugs i want to talk to you a
little bit
about the team and go into uh what you
have
in store for the game but first i want
to ask you a couple of
questions about the team and and how
you're moving forward
um so first of all for people who don't
know
where did your studio name inner sloth
come from
and who is repping the team
uh so when we first formed our
company mean forest
we were trying to come up with a name
and we were kind of just
stuck so we went on a random
name generation site and just like
clicked through clicked through
and inner sloth just kind of felt
for for me it was like i have the
motivation to
make stuff but like the inside of me is
kind of lazy kind of
it's hard to get motivated sometimes so
that the sloth really
stuck to me there you know some people
think that success is overnight but you
have all been grinding to make things
happen with such a small team
what have some of the challenges been
during the growth and iterative
development of the game
been um i would say
i mean just in general going from three
people to we're at eight now i think
is such a different work environment
completely
like getting everyone on the same page
is something that's we're all we're
still learning how to do meetings have
to start happening
you can't just tell i'm used to telling
one person and then
things go from there and now i have to
make sure to tell everyone and
and i have to learn how to write design
docs
i can't just have it in my head and tell
people
that's dope and you've been like an
integral part of the indie community
with helping out early on you know uh
with the mega booth and then
really orchestrating train jam and been
involved in so many projects
um how has it like i
i understand how you kind of joined the
team um how has it been on the
on the opposite end of like you know
communicating with marcus
and and everybody on the team um it's
been
it's been fun it's been fun to be sort
of in that transition from the small
team to what is quote unquote the larger
team now
not that eight is huge or anything but i
was
i was the fifth person so i was like
right at that tipping point from it
being
small enough where you could just tell
one person one thing and then everybody
knows everything
to now it's like we have to make sure
we're tagging all the right people
in our work channels and like getting
information out and
yeah i came on towards the end of last
year
um through a mutual friend who was like
hey
anderslaw needs needs more programmers
you know because at that point it was
just porous as the programmer and i was
like all right i'm in
and then yeah rest is history but it's
been it's been really fun
um getting to sort of grow the
programming team as well and take
at least some of the pressure off of
forest to be the only person doing that
kind of stuff and being able to
do more output and get things out there
faster so you've had like
you know notable celebrities you've had
aoc just mad people streaming it
and now it's really ingrained into pop
culture
um what are some of the most surreal
defining moments
that have been heartwarming uh or have
left an
impact on the team during since its uh
original release until now
just all of the like the fan art that
comes in
and all the like fan animations fan
uh like music videos remixes
just so much amazing stuff
we always we have a channel in our
discord that we just post all this stuff
and it's just like empowering drives
gives us motivation to keep going
you know you've really been maintaining
the life of the game
with really interesting updates and and
drops
um what can you share with everyone on
twitch watching during the guerrilla
collective
that is next for among us yeah we do
have 15 players coming
which means we do need more colors
because there's only 12 in the game
um and so we're going to add six new
colors
i don't know if that's been announced
but
i feel like we could we could say that
we did at one point have a color named
barf
that is not true at least so what is
that
like it's like a speckled yellow or
something
like a greenish yellow yeah okay
imagine mashed up peas like masterpiece
that you would feed a baby
wow like the barf emoji just that color
yeah
oh okay i i for one am disappointed that
we don't have barf in the game but
me too i was a big champion for barf
yeah
bring back barf no no barf
how do you come up with like because it
seems interesting that
just that you're just talking about you
know having the barf coke
uh colors how do you come up you know
with these these different designs and
ideas
the colors are super hard we're trying
to move away from
having colors be the main identifier for
each character
so we want to lean more into cosmetics
and names so but we still want to make
them at least it to begin with make them
as distinct as possible so i have to
like pull up all the colors we have
and then think about like look at the
color wheel and go okay maybe
we don't have anything in this little
zone i'll try something here
and i compare them together and it's
like this one does look really similar
to blue or like
i could see this one getting mixed up
with purple or something
but eventually we're just gonna have to
kind of
move away from that and not worry about
it as much
it's it's awesome to have you guys thank
you guys for
you know joining us for this um is there
anything that you wanted
that you want to tell the fans because
there's going to be a lot of people
probably watching this who want to know
about
among you know something straight from
the team i mean
just thank you that's the
the one that's just always there thank
you for playing thank you for liking the
game
yeah it's kind of that's the same
sentiment here
it's great it's it's mind-boggling to be
working on a game that this many people
play and get like such an enjoyment out
like i get texts from friends who are
like
well my 12 year old was was playing with
his friends and was bragging about
knowing that his mom knows you and i'm
just like oh
that is so that is awesome um
but yeah thank you thank you so much for
for joining us
uh we appreciate it it's been amazing
and we'll talk to you later thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
and now for the moment you've all been
waiting for king of the hat is coming to
steam
king of the hat is coming to the moment
you've all been waiting for which means
that you
can wish with the king if you wish the
game right now you could win
you
[Applause]
a sticker
oh my god wow you might be able to spin
every wheel
[Applause]
[Applause]
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
crime is illegal well not anymore
thanks to whitewater wipeout by chuhai
labs
thanks to whitewater wipeout i can
finally commit the cool crime
of surfing featuring pure gnar style
and conviction what does that even mean
it's a play-date game yeah jeff
yeah i'm on set i have no idea what the
script is no i'm not gonna hold
i'm mihoko i play white water
[Music]
whiteboard
at kingwash laundry we pride ourselves
on providing
years of garment cleaning excellence our
customers come for the
top of the line deluxe washing machines
but they stay
for our professional service
now pick up the clothes and load them
into an empty machine
wait a few minutes then transfer to a
dryer
while you're waiting make sure to pick
up discarded coffee cups
and throw them in the truck thank you
for choosing arcade mania
if you want to level up your takings and
grow your arcade just follow our simple
three-step plan
one play your new game and set a killer
high score
two now watch as customers drop quarters
trying to beat your score while you sit
back and make fat profits three use your
takings to buy a brand new cabinet from
arcade mania just use your personal
computer to surf the
internet and you can order online now
just wait for your new purchase to
arrive and do
it all again play profit purchase play
profit purchase
play profit pest control purchase with
these steps your arcade is guaranteed to
grow
and expand into a glorious arcade
paradise
full of our biggest hits good luck and
always choose our king always use the
brush
for particularly stubborn waste matter
all that remains to be said is welcome
to king wash laundry
[Music]
i am here with douglas bogart
from limited run games what is happening
doug
how much man thanks for having me yeah
for sure man
like it's so awesome that limited run
you know
has reached its five-year
anniversary um can you tell the people
about limited run games
if you know folks that aren't familiar
with it
yeah so let me run games we uh started
the company with my co-founder josh
fairhurst uh we started in
october 2015 as a response to uh his dev
company mighty rabbit studios having
trouble staying in business
we were off a big project and we didn't
have a whole lot of work
to do so we were like how do we stay in
business and then
his biggest thing was we had one game on
veda called preaching clear and he was
like you know it'd be cool to at least
preserve this game even if nobody wants
it so that way i have some proof that i
did something and it's not all digital
uh so we did that and we sold the game
in october and it
sold out in 108 minutes and uh
kind of blossomed from there you know
got contacted by epic
oddworld uh wayforward started really
pulling in the partners and
we've done like over like close to
700 800 individual releases now
super crazy man like what what is like
one of the highlights
uh of your career in limited run games
what you've done
there's a lot um so i had we had like a
wish list of things we wanted to do
originally and
we ended up doing all those but like i'd
probably say one of our biggest things
is scott pilgrim because
oh yeah that was like one of the
founding pillars of what we wanted to do
um and then for personally like working
with sudan no more heroes
was a huge deal for me uh working with
john romero on sigil
doing command and conquer with ea we've
just done a whole lot of cool stuff that
i never thought we'd be able to and i've
talked to a lot of
heroes i've always had and it's like i
don't know oh
the jay and silent bob game is a huge
deal for me like
you know without kevin smith josh and i
uh would never amended a friendship that
we had
briefly broken up uh when we were young
so
um you know what i think is really
interesting is
just your idea of doing things in that
you know in a limited quantity
can you kind of talk about like how like
what kind of
um different packages that you guys put
together
yeah so when limiter runs started off we
were definitely very limited and the
reasoning for that was
one it cost a lot of money and resources
to do it and we didn't want to be stuck
with overstock because we can't afford
to just sit on a product that takes
years to sell out
yeah um we started off with limited
stuff and as we got bigger
we decided with switch like hey we have
no idea what the audience is here why
don't we try open pre-orders and
that worked out really well and then
with the pandemic hitting we were like
you know what let's just
do this for most of our stuff going
forward and i think the reception's been
a lot better so
we're limited in like the amount of time
basically now versus the amount of unit
which i think is a better approach
because it
it gives people a chance to get it and
it's not so much that like oh i missed
out
um i mean people still miss out but now
we work with places like best buy amazon
and gamestop and some of our games are
available at retail which is another
cool thing for our developers because
you know as when you're younger you're
like man i wish one day my games could
be on the store shelf and now they can
um and yeah then we offer vinyl we do
collectors editions we do press kits for
companies we do a whole lot of stuff now
that's
pretty amazing we're always looking to
expand we're doing the retro stuff like
we did for janet silent bob
um yeah it's it's awesome i'm really
happy with the stuff we've been able to
do pretty much any idea here
you know if an employee or co-worker has
an idea it's like why don't we run with
it and see what happens and
just test it out because you know what
if you like it maybe there's an audience
for it
you guys have an event coming up can you
plug it real quick i want i think
everybody should watch it
talk about your upcoming releases and
stuff we're doing our own e3
presentation called lrg3 it's going to
be on june 14th at 4 00 pm eastern
and we got a whole bunch of cool games
in the lineup that we're excited about
um the show is being produced by one of
the gentlemen from mega 64 on his own
um so it's gonna be it's got the same
similar humor
and i don't know we just watched
actually the draft of the video and it's
really funny and i'm
kind of shocked actually that it came
together so well
that is so awesome i hope everybody can
check that out
you know um where can we find you more
information about limited run games
and everything that you guys are doing
yeah go to our website let me run
games.com there's a mailing list option
uh our twitter we update frequently at
limited run games we have a twitch
channel which is uh twitch.tv slash
limited run games and pretty much any
website you go to just add slash let me
run games you know you might find
us um i think at one point we even had
like a tumblr account so
we were everywhere yeah yeah maybe maybe
a pinterest account i don't know
go well thank you so much doug um it's
awesome to see you guys
flourish happy fifth anniversary and
everybody go check out lrg3 right
yep thank you so much for sure talk to
you later man
the inner sloth team was so humble and
they've had such a great journey
um you know congrats to them also
limited run games coming up on their
sixth year they've been five years
strong um working with any developers to
get their games out in a limited
capacity
in a physical kind of space you know so
so many great games and devs that have
uh blessed the gorilla collective this
year
shout out to them and thank you guys for
for joining us
yes and be sure to check out the
guerrilla collective event page on steam
where you can learn more about these
games buy the games that are available
now
or add the games to your wish list for
the games that have not been released
yet
wishlists help so do it i've said it
before
and i'll say it again we also want to
thank everybody who was involved to
making this production
possible uh wilmerson of course thank
you so much alex
it's so great to be in the space um
the mix team of course av society timmy
code 32 fully illustrated
everybody that has contributed also
thanks once again to our sponsors and
broadcasting partners for their support
gamespot twitch ign and steam you guys
are awesome for hosting the stream
also we want to shout out to our
sponsors
good shepherd humble games tiny build
playstation xbox
kickstarter razer astral gaming our
fellow devs and publishers
two awesome studio akupara games all in
games goblin studio
graffiti games head up hype train
digital neon doctrine raw fury
thunderful
and white thorn games that wraps up the
gorilla collective 2.
such a fun time with developers
worldwide and awesome partners
thank you for joining us we truly
appreciate it yes and before we head out
we're gonna show the wholesome direct
trailer and come back
with our friend jenny windham stay tuned
[Music]
such a cozy and warm trailer that was
very nice this is really really
nice sweet we have our friend jenny
windham aka
kim chico on the line to get started
with the wholesome direct
hey jenny how is it going yes
thanks justin and everyone at the
gorilla collective
also congratulations to all of the devsu
showcase you all did wonderfully i can't
wait to play all of your games
um and yeah stick around we have the
wholesome direct coming up with
new game announcements exclusive footage
developer interviews and it's just going
to be a wonderfully cozy time
so hope you all enjoy it thanks so much
jenny for joining us
looking forward to checking out the show
that wraps up the gorilla collective 2
i am your host justin woodward with
alex wilmer make sure to follow us on
twitter at gorillacollect
not gorilla collective and on all other
social media platforms at gorilla
collective you can check out the mix
at indiexchange on twitter and
everywhere else at media indie exchange
stay tuned for wholesome direct we will
see you all
soon peace
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is happening i am here with one of
the co-founders of wholesome games
matthew taylor he and his brother
started wholesome games
which sparked off wholesome direct can
you tell everyone
how wholesome games got started
well it started out really simple uh my
brother james and i just
were really excited about some upcoming
games at the time like i always go back
to
ooblets and mineko's night market as the
two that i was
really excited about and it just kind of
seemed like there was a little bit of
momentum building for those kinds of
games
uh and then wholesome games was just a
twitter account that
curated that stuff and then that grew
into a discord
and then last year that all kind of
culminated in folsom direct which is
probably what most people know us for
now
that's dope wait so uh the discord is
that open to the developers
and uh also the audience or just the
audience
i didn't even know there was a discord i
should have known that yeah
the discord is like not the biggest
discord not the smallest but i really
like it i think we have a great
community on there and it's a really
great mix of developers
and fans so i think you get people from
you know every walk of the industry in
there and i think that's what makes it
such a cool
welcoming space yeah for sure so what
what year did you guys get started and
can you tell us
go a little bit more in depth into the
origins of
uh wholesome games well i think we got
started
in 2019 and like i said it was just a
twitter account at first
um i think james and his friend jacob
they were in various discords for these
games like ooblets
and you would see the same people crop
up
and like everybody whether they knew it
or not was kind of
attracted to this similar type of game
and so i think that led
very quickly to people thinking huh
maybe there's something to this like if
we put this together
we'll see how many people come out for
it and like a lot of things you do like
you just put it together and see if
anyone shows up and
both developers and way more fans than i
ever anticipated
uh are excited for these kinds of games
and excited for
anyone to help find them and curate them
i mean
yeah i love these type of games and it's
cool that you
are directly curating and working with
these developers
and just in general you know and also
the grassroots approach is
basically how we started the gorilla
collective in the mix um
i'm a developer too and i know you guys
are developers can you
talk a little bit about um how you got
started in game development
uh our game development journey started
because
my brother every story starts with my
brother apparently
but we like grew up making music
together and doing all this stuff and
then he went to college for something
completely unrelated to game development
but there was just a little there are a
few programming classes and he
got excited about that kind of had this
renewed love
for programming and we said well maybe
let's like make one game
before you go to college go to the real
world start your start your real job
and so we did that and it took off just
a little bit just enough for us to feel
encouraged and then
we never looked back and uh now we're
making rolling hills which is by far
our biggest game we've ever made um but
yeah i mean
i think everyone has their own story
about how they got into game development
for us it was just let's
let's try it maybe it's not as scary as
it looks and
uh you just get just a little bit of
encouragement and when you really want
to do something
all it takes is that little bit yeah for
sure rolling hills looks
gorgeous by the way thank you so much so
it's
looks so dope when i found i didn't even
know at first that you guys were working
on a game
you know let alone you know sometimes
there's this like
mysterious entity like behind these
events it's like
who is working on these events and then
you know uh the mutual friend you know
jenny kimchiko i was like she said
you know she was one of the hosts at
your level and i was like can i get in
contact with these folks i love what
they're doing so that's
it's really awesome to be able to
connect you know uh you know face to
face at least
digitally now yeah yeah
i mean honestly we felt the same way
about you guys last year we were like
well
there's this big thing called gorilla
collective i don't know much about it
but man it looks huge
for sure what is the response been from
developers
about you know just wholesome games and
and wholesome direct
it's been really positive i think people
are really appreciative anytime like we
try to be really honest that everything
is for the games you know everything we
do is to bring attention to the
developers
and i think developers can tell that
there's that honesty to it
and then in terms of the direct that's
what i'm most impressed because
last year no one knew how folsom direct
was going to turn out and we still had
developers
that we loved for a lot of time into
trailers and i was like so cool you know
y'all don't really know
how it's going to turn out they put so
much faith that we weren't going to mess
it up
and then uh you know this year i guess
there's a little more assurance that
we're going to do our best
but there was a lot of faith and i think
that's just a reflection of
how excited people are for pearls and
games in general
yeah yeah congrats on that i know how it
is flying by the seat of your pants and
just trying to make it
make something happy i think i mean
happen um
and happy too i think what is really
interesting is
being able to be agile enough to do that
as a small you know like as a uh
you know a community and that's what the
guerrilla collective
is is a community of developers and
publishers and we were
we were able to you know kind of foresee
what
troubles were gonna happen last year
during this like you know this
the lack of e3 and just you know voltron
it up you know what i mean
um yeah i think it kind of leveled the
playing field for everybody because
there were all these established events
but you know it's almost like music
production you know or like it used to
be a big studio and now it's just a
laptop
it's like well it's just a laptop we can
get our friends together
and try to do it on our own and that's
what we did that's that's
that's amazing you guys uh you know put
a piece of vinyl out
from the music uh that was from the
music from the developers who showcased
that wholesome games in wholesome direct
and
and it seems like you have a mission and
really want to make a social impact
there's a charitable factor can you can
you talk a little bit about that
yeah i think it's just one of those
things where to be honest on one level
we want to produce cool merch and we
want the proceeds to go to something
important
uh it's a really good opportunity for us
to use wholesome games which we never
expected to have any kind of platform to
begin with but now that you do you know
what are you going to do with it
so with the vinyl we were able to take
all those proceeds to the galaxy fund
which is a
first of its kind grant for women by
pocket and lgbt plus lead teams
in the game industry um they're
they're kind of their own thing you know
where they're like kind of scrappy like
we are and just trying to
do what they can to make the world a
better place make the industry a better
place
and then today uh on wholesome direct we
partnered with the irc which is an
organization that responds to the worst
humanitarian crisis
or crises part of me and uh
yeah and in both cases it's just like if
you're gonna have this opportunity
to reach people uh and you're gonna be
called wholesome games at some point you
gotta determine what is wholesome
and we think these things are are
wholesome
that is that is so true that is pretty
awesome that you guys are doing that um
for my last question i like to ask what
advice would you give
up and coming developers regarding their
vision um
you know to develop cozy style games
i think you know the the through line
for me
really wholesome cozy it can all vary
and there's a lot of great resources out
there for like
specific design elements and i'm sure
people who
who play these types of games will
quickly see like reoccurring themes
but as cheesy as it is for me like
putting your heart into it like if you
make something that really speaks to you
you're not just making
you know another farming game or
whatever it may be you're following
trends just
put your heart into it and when you do
that you're gonna come up with
innovative ideas and i think that's one
of the beautiful things about wholesome
games is it challenges people
to find a lot of different things they
can do with games maybe compared to the
things we're used to in mainstream games
yeah for sure actually i lied i have one
more question
because you just kind of brought it up
we were talking about it before but
what would you consider a wholesome game
like you just said it's not just farming
simulators it's not just like yeah
cute critters right like there's a wide
variety of games that can
kind of fit in that how what would you
consider a
a wholesome game it's really tough i
think it's one of those things where
the more you follow us and certainly
anyone who watches holston direct today
by the end of it we'll have a pretty
good understanding of what fits
uh for me i think one of the three lines
is uplifting in general like you can go
through really dark moments i always
love spirit fair as an example which we
had in last year's direct
uh that's a game that brings a lot of
people to tears it's a game that goes
through
really harsh moments and you know
doesn't really shy away from any of that
that's one of the things i love about
wholesome games is we've created this
space where
you can absolutely go as deep and in
some cases as dark as you want but
there's always that element of
kind of humility and humanness at the
core of it and that element of heart
and i i really appreciate that it's not
cynical in the way some things might be
yeah but yeah i think uh in in general
anything that kind of has that uplifting
or heartfelt nature that's
what i look for that's cool definitely
has soul
um yeah so where can we find out about
wholesome direct where can we follow you
uh and all that
and wholesome games not just wholesome
direct yeah yeah
uh we're gonna make it easy we're gonna
do wholesome games.com for everything
we'll have links to the twitter which is
where a lot of people know us from
uh links to any merch that we're doing
with the yeti and the irc
and uh the biggest thing is at the end
of the show we'll have a full list of
every game there so we'll make it really
easy to go
wish list follow support and you know at
the end of the day it is about the
developers so we'll try to make it easy
for everyone to find them
for sure and wholesome direct is coming
up really soon so everybody stay tuned
for that thank you so much matthew
i appreciate you and you know everybody
involved will hold some games and hold
some direct
awesome thank you jeff all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to wholesome direct a
celebration of wholesome games
my name is jenny windham and i am joined
by my co-host victoria tran and derek
fields
sit back and relax as we bring you
exclusive footage from 75 wholesome
games and remember if you see any games
you love today head over to
wholesomegames.com to get all the info
and find out how you can support the
developers
all right let's get started
[Music]
me
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what channel is that coming on
ricolit is a mysterious adventure game
where you explore a strange town by
following trails of light
during your journey you'll help the
residents of this town by using items
illuminated by the light to progress the
[Music]
story
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
are you glaring
[Music]
so
[Music]
like taking photos engaged slapping on a
filter
slapping on stickers i'm into it i'm
into it
hi i'm annie and i'm lucas and we are
max inferno and we're very excited to
introduce to you our tidy puzzle game a
little to the left
it's a game where you stack sort and
organize things into just the right spot
yep wait does that look crooked to you
it's okay i can fix it
[Music]
good
[Music]
do
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
we're just getting started but i'd love
to take a moment to mention our
collaboration with the international
rescue committee
there are now more than 80 million
refugees and displaced people around the
world who have been forced out of their
homes
the irc provides emergency aid and
long-term support to refugees and those
displaced by war persecution or natural
disasters
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
some limited time wholesome direct merch
like this incredible 3d acrylic stand as
well as a t-shirt featuring games
from today's event five dollars from
every product sold goes to the
international rescue committee
while wholesome games often show us what
a kinder world can look like
we hope this reminds you to never forget
the suffering in our own world
and what we can do to help if you'd like
to learn more you can visit rescue.org
wholesome games or follow at rescue or
on twitter
[Music]
cast spells be queer and crash the
biggest concert of the year
spirit spots is an action puzzle game
set in a lush
narrative driven world of witchy demons
swap to the beat as you reassemble lost
spirits enjoy the lo-fi
soundtrack decorate your bedroom and
hang with friends
[Music]
behind the frame is a narrative driven
puzzle game
features a unique painting mechanic 360
degree panoramic scenes
and a totally custom soundtrack
[Music]
hi i'm megan fox lead developer on
skateboard
skate games have a history of being
input dense
and using every button on the gamepad
and requiring rapid inputs to boot
skateboard is no exception as you can
see here but
i wanted to see if i could simplify that
at all
so i started looking at ways of reducing
buttons and thus
how much hand travel is required during
gameplay
the easiest one was auto push on ollie
hold ollie down you go forward
even classic skate games did this one
but it helps avoid input density
on the left stick after that i wanted to
try and reduce
how much your right hand moves so i
started by merging grind denali
normally pulling off a grind requires
moving your hand from the bottom of the
gamepad
face all the way to the top but now it's
just an easy double tap of the bottom
button
add in the option that slows the game
down being able to grab or kick flip
with just one button too
and hopefully anyone will be able to
have fun skateboarding with the bird but
skateboard releases
soup
here comes niko is the cozy 3d
platformer for tired people
[Music]
what we're seeing now is a showcase of
some of the friendly quirky characters
you'll meet in the game
[Music]
oh did i mention your boss is a frog
[Music]
hey everyone i'm saffron and i'm the
creative director at kitten cup studio
we're making pico a cozy tea making
simulator
where you run a tea house in a town full
of cats
we're really excited for you to see what
we've been working on and we hope that
if you love tea and cats as much as we
do then you'll come check us out
[Music]
pico is a cute cat-filled tea making
simulation game about taking the time
for self-care
and connecting with the things that make
you happy
as the town's newest resident and tea
house owner you'll learn 12 unique
rituals and tea making styles
[Music]
meet meredith weiss a hard-working
career woman in the big city
1986. she decides to take a break
and goes back to her hometown to become
a mail carrier
[Music]
it's hardly a chore driving a mail truck
around
such magnificent scenery meeting people
is also part of the job some of them are
familiar
many are new some of them are friendly
some are very busy some are happy
some seem happy some like cats while
others just want their mail and some of
them
she could get to know a little bit
better
who knows what will happen in two weeks
meredith might even change a few lives
including her own
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i will see you there there's so much to
that game i'm excited for it all the
little characters and their names
especially were they're
just a cute touch already
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
atlas is a grand adventure on an
uncharted planet
venture out into a new world full of
potential beautiful landscapes
unique characters and untold secrets
[Music]
woof
[Music]
woof
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the the team behind letters of written
adventure
the game is about sarah a young girl
from switzerland who is writing letters
to her pen friend
thanks to these letters she is able to
communicate her feelings
hopes and dreams as the game progresses
and sarah gets older
there will be different sides to the
story for you to discover depending on
the words that you chose
[Music]
ibm games presents letters
follow the life of sarah through all the
good times and bad times
help her find her voice to fight
monsters and use the power of words in
this nostalgic pen pal adventure
[Music]
look for it later this year on steam and
also nintendo switch
[Music]
you're alone on a cold christmas night
stuck at home in a foreign country
that's okay though
you'll get through it by cooking a hot
dish intended for six people
[Music]
hotpot for one is a short experience
about the bitterness of lonely times and
the sweet comfort of food that keeps us
[Music]
going
traverse the grove as a guardian grape
protect friends gather precious
materials and repair social ties and
structures
by bringing the community of each
village together as they work to fend
off the rot
[Applause]
guide concorde's restoration efforts and
earn the trust of the community
[Music]
tracks of thought is an rpg shaped by
your own personality
[Music]
find common ground in card based battles
and overcome your pitfalls together
ready to confront yourself be sure to
catch the demo on steam
right now
hi everyone i'm michelle olson the game
director of beasts of maruvia island
visa maravia island is a game about
discovering extraordinary creatures
learning their behaviors and most
importantly photographing their majesty
my team and i are so excited for you to
meet all of marvey island's magical
inhabitants
and see the amazing photos that you take
embark on your adventure in the hidden
magic jungles of mara via island
assume the role of an aspiring wildlife
photographer armed with her
grandfather's camera
and a field guide of maravia island
explore
discover extraordinary creatures
interact with them in their natural
habitat
and photograph the enchanting unique
behaviors you reveal
on your journey through the magic
jungles you'll climb explore
and solve puzzles with the island's
flora and fauna
to find and photograph as fabulous
beasts
play with a rambunctious otter crocodile
be the wingman for a love-struck bird
monkey
and discover the favorite hiding spots
of birds disguised as
[Music]
bananas
east of maravilla island is out today
[Music]
hi i'm sun cha from square cat studio
and we're making
hua we had a lot of fun at wholesome
direct last may
and we're super excited to be back again
with some new updates
this time we have some exclusive footage
as well as
an announcement mix so do stay tuned
till the end of the video
so this time we're underground this
is home to the flying rocks
as you match each of them to their own
cloud
of light they will become
the curious moving platforms
[Music]
since last year at wholesome direct our
ferry has come a long
long way and now that she's almost ready
to meet everyone
we would like to say thank you for being
all the while supportive and kind
today we are really happy to announce
that i will be coming to you guys
on the 21st of august 2021
we cannot wait for everyone to join this
journey and see you then
bye bye three
two one one
zero okay here we go hi i'm mitsumi
i play piano when i can get someone to
actually pay me
itsu this house has lawn games did you
see luca hey hey it's my friend luca
luca is the planet saturn because he's
far away and carter is a shooting star
because they have long sweaters and do
wishes
exactly thank you itsu this is jay
jay is scary but in a hot way and is
also a genius but for your ears
[Music]
everyone in los angeles is mourning
something glad to have you with us
[Music]
i don't really know what i even want to
say with music you gotta have
something to say if anything you're
honest
and when you're honest saying anything
is something special
for those just joining we'd like to
remind you of our collaboration with the
international rescue committee
more than 80 million people are upgraded
by crisis worldwide
that's the highest number ever recorded
the rsc helps people survive
recover and gain control of their future
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
limited time wholesome direct items like
this incredible 3d acrylic stand
as well as a t-shirt featuring games
from today's event five dollars from
every product sold goes to the
international rescue committee if you'd
like to learn more you can visit
rescue.org
wholesome games or follow at rescue
oregon twitter
thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm trent and this is my grandma hi
and we're here to show you a trailer for
my new game a walk
with yaya it's about walking your
grandma around the neighborhood after
she's had a scary fall and you're trying
to build her confidence back up what did
you think about the trailer gaga
it was good if your grandma likes
something that means it's good
[Music]
bonjour i'm cerie babush the art
director of
arjuna sequoia working with hume
animation on a watercolor adventure
darden darden follows mimi a young woman
revisiting her childhood memories
through puzzles and letters that her
grandmother left for her
everything in darden is hand painting on
paper before being brought to life again
through the adventure you will help mimi
builder journal with the photos
sounds and the words you will find
before long mimi's journal will be full
of memories of the summers you will have
spent with her come over and
[Music]
a nostalgic adventure darden is brimming
with feeling and heart
help me me see once again through the
eyes of the little girl who marveled at
everything
when dardon launches later this year on
pc
and nintendo switch we can't wait to
show you more
this is gorgeous yeah i got little
chills watching that that was so nice
it's like you get to take pictures but
also you know how when you have
childhood memories and sometimes there's
like sounds that you really like and i
like
you get to like also use sounds in your
scrapbook that's really really cool
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in tasamachi behind the twilight you'll
join yukimo in her journey to repair her
beloved airship in a mysterious silent
town
[Music]
[Music]
meet the nezu tribe and unravel secrets
when tasamachi releases on consoles
in 2021
i like running around as a fox nature's
better when you're a fox
novels of course my personal favorites
are
austin and elliot i live to see the
smiles of others
that includes yours easy
i like to win my wife's mountain i
really love dinosaurs the mornings that
tommy and i eat breakfast together are
my favorite
please be happy demo available now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
leap into battle cakes and forge the
path of a cupcake hero
you create
[Music]
explore pastelyria an enchanted kingdom
that's jam-packed full of magic
mystery and the many friends you'll meet
along the way in this cozy turn-based
[Music]
rpg
oh i'll tell you all about pine ball
it used to be such a great spot
charming and beautiful
now it's a dump no wonder nobody steps
foot in this place anymore
you'd have to go out there and clean up
the joint
get some new furniture and remodel
everything
and even after all that you'd still need
to take care of the critters
stretch the swamp and throw out
all the garbage oh and you
probably should do something about
whatever's
lurking out there
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hi i'm invalia member of the call police
details what you just saw is the reveal
of our first game
sally if you like to learn more about it
make sure to follow us at lucidtells and
join us on youtube for our new series
gamedev tales
see you soon in rainbow billy
you start your journey in star harbor a
peaceful island in the world of
imagination
until suddenly the leviathan awakens
from his slumber
and curses the world to black and white
along with billy's sidekicks rodrigo and
friendship they embark on an epic
journey to recolor
every island solve puzzles and complete
various trials in order to befriend
colorless creatures
like eggins by confronting these
creatures and showing empathy to
understand what they're going through
their missing colors are revealed and
with the help of your friends they're
fully restored to their whimsical selves
[Music]
billy's new friends join the adventure
and have a new home aboard friendship
take care of your new friends by feeding
them gummy fish to strengthen your bond
rainbow billy the curse of the leviathan
will be launching later this year
adding this game to your wish list would
mean the world to us
thanks for watching
[Music]
unpacking is a game about taking
possessions out of boxes and learning
about someone's life over a series of
moves
you're not living by yourself this time
so it's up to you to figure out how to
fit in
[Music]
soup pot is a cooking game with a focus
on creativity
[Music]
cook freely with a wide range of
ingredients and explore plating styles
in various traditional kitchens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
teacup is a wholesome narrative
adventure with a focus on exploration
and non-linear progression
[Music]
help a small and shy frog on her journey
to find the ingredients
she needs for her tea party
[Music]
hello i'm zach and i'm lou and we're the
co-founders of bunny hug
after the initial overwhelming response
to moonglo bay we've seen a wonderful
community grow and made many new friends
speaking of friends we wanted to share
with the wholesome community a sneak
peek into the friendship system of the
fishing tile that is afraid to fish
[Music]
so
[Music]
paparazzi is a game about taking photos
of cute dogs
[Music]
explore the world and find all the pups
like in this newly revealed area
[Music]
metropolis
[Music]
luna's fishing garden is a cozy fishing
and building game
[Music]
catch fish trade them in and create the
garden of your dreams by planting new
trees
placing objects and bringing animals to
the archipelago
[Music]
witchery academy is a live sim where you
play as a wizard apprentice
your magical skills by attending classes
don't forget to take care of your garden
too
you'll meet other apprentices and
explore the academy
[Music]
you can even spend time bonding with
your spirit companion
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to amber isle
[Music]
on this peaceful island you are tasked
with running your very own shop
and befriending the local prehistoric
animal villagers the paleofolk
craft items customize your shop and
character and expand the village to meet
the needs of your paleo folk neighbors
[Music]
one last time we'd like to talk about
our collaboration with the international
rescue committee
the irc is one of the only organizations
that works across the entire arc of
crisis
providing immediate relief to millions
whose lives have been shattered by
conflict
disaster and climate change and helping
refugees to rebuild their lives once
they have found safety
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
some limited time wholesome direct merch
like this incredible 3d acrylic stand as
well as a t-shirt featuring games from
today's event
five dollars from every product sold
goes to the international rescue
committee and if you'd like to learn
more
you can visit rescue.org wholesome games
or follow at rescueorg on twitter
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
frog song is a heartfelt adventure where
it's okay to be small
[Music]
[Applause]
talk to cute froggy characters and
protect yourself from monsters on your
journey to prove that you
can be a hero too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's almost time to say goodbye before
we go we'd like to share even more
wholesome games coming your way this
year
and beyond these are going to go by fast
so don't forget to visit
wholesomegames.com
after the show for all the info and
links to everything
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and that brings us to the end of our
program remember to visit
wholesomegames.com
for links to every game in the show as
an indie developer myself
i can say for certain that just a follow
or wish list can make all the difference
we'll see you again next year for
wholesome direct 2022
but it wouldn't be a real showcase
without one last surprise
so here's one more game we hope you'll
love bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you